thank you thanks so this is joint work
with zine bang who's in the audience
Nancy Lynch Muriel mattered who are at
MIT and Peter Musial who's at emc
corporation so this is an application of
distributed storage systems and the
applications have what I have shown here
suppose I have a distributed storage
system and I want to use the stock use
it to store say the stock market stock
market data or let's say I want to use
it for distributed computing for cloud
computing and things like that in these
systems well you want it to be a
well-oiled distributed storage system so
you want failure tolerance you want low
storage costs you want fast reads and
writes in addition to these standard
constraints there is another constraint
that is called consistency that is the
if the value is changing if your stock
stock value is changing when I read I
should get the latest value of this talk
now in the application of distributed
computing suppose one processor changes
the value of some variable another
processor that is reading the value from
this distributed storage system should
get the change value okay so the goal of
this talk is to understand how some some
quantities about this about implementing
a consistent distributed storage so as
the theme of the workshop is from
practice to theory so the practice the
application that I am interested in is
implementing a consistent distributed
storage the goal is to use tools of
information theory coding theory to
understand costs or performance to
understand storage costs to understand
communication cause of this of a
consistent distributed storage system so
to do this we need a model right so we
want to understand this theoretically we
need a model so this has been modeled
and well studied in in the field of
distributed computing there is a problem
called the shared memory a Malaysian
problem in distributed computing that
models this notion of consistency in
storage systems
so in this talk I will talk about I will
introduce the shared memory a Malaysian
problem and then I will talk about the
coding theory or an information theory
problem that tries to understand the
costs of this shared memory emulation
problem so the shared memory memory a
Malaysian is a proxy for the application
this this model is the proxy for that
application ok so I'll begin with a
brief history of shared memory emulation
so if these concepts were originally
formulated by Lamport the idea of a
consistency or what is called atomicity
was formulated by Lamport in 1986 and it
has gone on to become a cornerstone of
distributed computing in multiprocessor
programming if you study things like
databases you understand out one of the
things you learn is this concept of an
atomic shared memory another place where
people learn this common least when the
mini learn multiprocessor programming
when people use an atomic shared memory
to make the threads talk to each other
so these are standard concepts in
several computer science courses are you
going to explain us exactly what I
really explain it to you approximately
what it is I won't define define this
so this is a concept an atomic shared
memory is a concept the question is if I
want to use a distributed storage
distributed storage system to emulate
this concept there's this field of
emulation shared memory emulation in
distributed systems one of the first
algorithms that came up it's abbreviated
as the ABD algorithm in after the
author's names and this this actually 11
the diced reprise in 2011 so it's a
celebrated algorithm in this field and
actually modern data centers which
implement databases like the Amazon
dynamo key value store the algorithms
that they use in these data centers
actually mimic these these algorithms
that I'll talk about but the main thing
is these are fault tolerant algorithms
so the they built fault tolerance into
the in the storage system the main thing
is that their replication based that is
where we would come in right so i will
talk about some challenges and ideas for
using coding for for for shared memory
emulation and these challenges will
inspire my multi version coding problem
which and so let me just introduce these
concepts briefly so the model is the
following you have a distributed storage
systems you have several servers you
have to you have a client-server
architecture so server store values
clients are things that come and want to
write or read a value so you imagine a
single value being stored a right client
essentially wants to update this value a
real client wants to come in and it it
it wants to read values from the system
it typically wants to read the latest
value clients and servers are connected
connected through point-to-point links
thats how they that's how they
communicate the model for the links is
that they it's like traffic in
California I begin I reached my
destination I don't know when I reached
there because of the traffic but I reach
there so these are point-to-point
reliable asynchronous links
nords can fails client and the server
nodes and client nodes can fail but it
is a distributed architecture so I don't
know even another node fails or I don't
know anything about the state of any
other node except from the messages that
I exchange from the word I know the
topology but I do not know the current
state when it fails whether it has
failed except from the messages so I
think this is a good model it turns out
to be a useful model I think this is
because a storage systems scale it's
harder to achieve synchronization it's
harder to achieve some kind of
coordination so I think these models
have turned out to be useful for this
large scale storage systems for this
reason ok this is the model underlying
model what's our goal watch what should
I do so the goal is to design protocols
for these so the algorithms protocols
for these for the clients right right
protocols for the right clients server
protocols and read protocols so that's
the goal yep to write clients try to
write concurrently on the same days is
it so one of the two the one who likes
later will be written fully or with some
garbage of the two page will mix how
does it work so the links are pipelines
links are fine but I'm saying if I try
to write 0 0 0 1 0 1 and you
concurrently with me try to write
something as one so you write first your
right is implemented first and then my
right is so my right it's an atomic yeah
ok so it's not that I will write half of
my [ __ ] then your [ __ ] get on top of
no so I mean even if that happens that
abstraction is not captured hear it it's
a it's a single operation that's the
model well
any other questions overrated nothing
except on purpose that might be the
client-server protocol might say
overwrite it but the channel by itself
doesn't overwrite it that's the model so
the goal is to design these protocols so
that the operations are concurrent so I
should be able to come in right and
return even if there are other
operations happening in parallel so you
want concurrent reads and writes it's
not like once one right client comes and
locks the entire storage system that
that should not happen that's the first
requirement the second requirement is
consistency or atomicity so atomicity as
I mentioned is was introduced by Lamport
in 86 if you want to understand
algorithms for this over this
architecture that people use you need to
understand the precise definition of
atomicity here I will only tell you what
is required for this talk what is
required for the later coding problem
that we need this is as I mentioned a
butchered definition of atomicity for
simplicity so the idea is the following
after the write operation completes any
read that begins after of the right
completes should either return the value
of that right or it should return the
value of a right that overlaps with this
right so that either begins off begins
in the interval or ends in the interval
of this right or it should return the
value of a right that begins after this
right completes so any later rate should
return the most reasonable thing yeah
let me show this picture so this this
this the bottom is the rate the top is
the right so the bottom thing should
return we have one it shouldn't return
something older this is ritesh well this
way to appa sorry this is time
horizontal axis this time the first
value it's just an indicator of the
value so that means
somebody started writing v1 and then
finished writing it there and then side
so the right protocol let's start sorry
it started here and finished there so
some blue person wrote the one and then
another blue pressure on reddit let it
started reading and ended reading here
and it returned me one yellow thing is
somebody else right it can be the same
person somebody else it's a distributed
system but we do is a different place in
memory or a different value it's a
different value started by a client
somebody else came and wanted to update
this value the same variable XI same
variable same variable okay okay so why
why when this person the second blue
read there he's still going to read v1
yeah so the idea that the rules are the
rules come in after the right completes
so after the edge of this any future one
should be able to see it that's the
that's the main idea well there are no
rules I mean there are but i am not
mentioning them there are no rules about
something that happened here if there
was a right that started here started
here and ended here they so then this
could have returned one of those two
that's what i mean by the overlapping
rights how about the 2v choose and are
there the beat you right hasn't finished
with this could have returned this can
return this it should return something
this or something later something that
started later it should it better it's
yeah yes yes this is fair game if it
happens if this happens in the
shamanistic if Dean done it's not
necessarily dude you're forcing is that
after the after the edge admitted come
who has ended right you don't allow v1
exactly exactly but you can allow for no
because that has not started and it's
physically not plausible but it's I
guess the rules don't put the third
entry which is conquering this bg1 to
the future is v1 yes yeah well you know
that that's not possible but i am not
that you don't need to know that for
what followers but that's not possible
okay so there is there are hidden things
in that once we switch to another go
body I egg but that you don't need to
know this these intricacies for what
follows okay this will make a bit more
sense as we go along hopefully good so
I'll give an idea of the algorithm to
mix maybe that gives more sense so the
APD algorithm as I mentioned is a
replication based replication based
algorithm the idea is that i right i
have core a quorum set quorum set is
just a majority the idea is that if i
write write to a quorum and read from a
quorum anybody that reads because to any
two currents intersect right is visible
to any future read so i write to a
majority of servers are read from a
majority of servers any two guys which
intersect intersect can get access to a
can see this written value that's the
main idea I because I don't know when
when I send a packet to this guy I do
not know if it has failed or not so this
this would become more sense in these
pictures so there's a value that comes
up this is the right protocol it sends
the value to all the servers right and
then the server send an acknowledgement
that is the server protocol as long as
it gets values from a quorum from a
majority it returns there's that's
basically the right protocol
similarly a reed sends a read request to
all the servers it doesn't know who has
failed who's alive it sends packets to
everybody servers respond with their
with a value that they store as long as
it gets values from at least one quorum
it picks the highest time-stamped value
and it returns the highest time-stamped
value so this makes the ABD algorithm
look very simple and trivial there are
actually additional steps the read
actually has to has an additional right
back step and things like that I am NOT
going to talk about those details
because they are not relevant to the
problem but there is some there there is
some tricky mathematics behind this
behind proving that this this algorithm
is is atomic but the most important
thing to remember in this for this talk
is that abd uses replication for fault
tolerance that is the most important
thing to remember
well it that's how the protocol works
they just used application they didn't
think about performance or storage costs
or communication costs and it works
because of majority so let's try to do
coding with this and see some of the
some of the challenges in one so the LG
show show this show the idea of coding
through and through a 64 MDS code so i
have a packet right and i divide it into
four parts and then generate to say
linear combinations to get a 64 MDS
codes so any four packets get me my
value and the standard coding argument
should hopefully apply since each of
these packets is just a quarter if every
server stores just a quarter of the
value and if I just communicate just
smaller packets i should say both on
storage costs and communication costs
hopefully but there is a new constraint
for this because of this consistency the
new constraint is that a reader a
decoder should get four packets of the
same of the same time stamp so there's
an additional implied synchrony that
that has to be ensured by the protocol
so this creates some interesting
challenges so I show a coding coding
example so here a quorum should has to
has to be five server nodes because any
two currents have to intersect in four
nodes I need for people to reconstruct
the pocket when I write and when I read
the there has to be an intersection of
four people for me to reconstruct a
quorum is just some subset of server
nodes the idea that if I write to five
nodes and you read from five nodes will
intersect in in at least four nodes so
my right is you will be able to see my
value
those are not clear quorum is just a
word for the number of people I have to
access the minimum number of people I
need to talk to before returning so let
me demonstrate why this is challenging
so let's say a right comes it's it sends
value V it sends coded packets to
everybody this packet so the original
state is this this sends packets to
everybody right and these are smaller
packets this reaches and these guys are
stuck in traffic I want concurrent
operations so let us say a reed comes
and sensory requests right these are
asynchronous links the order can be
anything now what should this guy douche
what should this return
this reader needs needs four packets of
the same time stamp so out there so this
this is interesting question firstly I
cannot erase the new old packet I need
to store some history to achieve the
synchronization that coding imposes
right so that's that's one challenge
another is what should I what I should
reveal to a new reader is also quite
quite challenging it's not obvious what
I should reveal to the new put this time
stamp and they're either just keep out
of the stuff he gets look you most
recent one was the problem with that it
would involve sending a lot firstly how
much it would in all storing a lot of
history it's in what it would involve
sending a lot of lot of package to the
reader what other thing is every time
you write something to one of them I am
going stop I know when you love it right
so have a time stuff we can assume that
they're so then when when the read
client asks for it like the people will
give him okay this is my what I think it
is at time t minus one but one of them
will say well this is what I think it is
a time T and he will look at them and
only keep the watch what's a man using
transom with the asynchrony maybe this
packet the raid can have started after
the right or before there I didn't quite
understand your question but I think you
might be missing the asynchrony why
don't you just send the timestamps and
then the you said yeah so that that's a
part of the protocol I won't go into the
protocol but the protocol initially read
sometimes protocol initially agrees on
some time stamps but I all I want to
convey is that this is not completely
obvious that you get the gains of coding
in the most natural way that's the only
thing I want to convey here and these
are some of the challenges and yeah week
I can go into more details of the
algorithmic aspect offline so these
challenges have been recognized by
people in this field people started
working back in 2004 to implement
erasure coding and there have been many
algorithms which we also wrote a paper
recently the differences between these
algorithms are like as I mentioned some
some some
algorithm send the entire history to so
that incur incurs a large communication
cause different some algorithms don't do
any garbage collection they store the
entire history and so we solved some of
these challenges and I'm like as
mentioned i can talk about the
algorithmic aspects offline so the
insights I'll just summarize the
insights from these algorithms so so the
insights are the following servers must
or symbols corresponding to multiple
versions I cannot just keep one coded
packet and make the algorithm work and
the number of coded packets that I keep
actually is related to the amount of
concurrency in the system so the number
of coded pack if the number of rights
that are concurrent with the reed is
larger then this my storage costs
actually increases for for coding for
for these algorithms so the question
that motivated our problem is the
following are these costs fundamental is
this dependency on concurrency
fundamental or is there can I use some
clever coding ideas to do something
better for this for this shared memory
emulation problem so this is the main
motivation for our for for the top for
the coding problem that I will talk
about any questions so far there's just
one thing that bothers me a little bit
i'm not sure why does it that why does
it allow you to retrieve version 2 once
version 2 starts to being written it's
being written i mean in your diagram
that that's just the rules of the game
so that is that's writing is not done
how can i access it could have happened
here even here in a BD right
oh you can just start reading and you
don't have to yeah yeah yeah because the
concurrency is allowed so yeah so it's a
carefully thought-out definition
actually the atomicity you can't it's
harder to come up with a stronger
definition stronger ordering but those
are just the rules of the game which
yeah okay so so now I will talk about
the coding problem so this is a coding
problem which I talked about yesterday
as well but let me this be define it so
the coding problem is the following they
have a storage system right I have many
versions that I need to support a
version one comes so I just in this
picture i am assuming version one is
there everywhere version 2 comes in and
then it's received by some servers and
not received by some servers right and
so on so each other get some subset of
versions because they of the inherent
asynchrony in this system a decoder
should access some subset of some
specified number of sub set of servers
and the rule of the game is that it
should be decode the latest common
version or something something later so
decoder can i meet these two and return
what it has to return version to a
decoder that accesses these two guys can
return version one that is thought of as
fair a decoder that accesses connects
these two should return version one or
version two so that's the goal of the
coding problem so each server stores a
function of the versions it has heard
from so in general a client connects to
see servers and demands the latest
common version among the v among the
subset of servers it connects to so the
three parameters are n servers v
versions and c is the connectivity and
the goal of my coding problem is to
minimize the worst case storage costs
right there are two solutions we already
saw application encoding the goal is to
figure out what's the smallest
storage costs this is just a first order
problem that we are looking at you can
talk about communication costs and add
other things on top of it which are
actually relevant to the problem but
this is what I'll storage cost is what I
will talk about here and two there are
two natural solutions based on you might
already guess these the two natural
solutions are the first one is
replication so each one just store each
server just stores the latest of all the
versions the message in its entirety
that's a replication based solution and
the storage size is the size of one
version the other naturally obvious
solution is that a server does not
delete anything among the V versions
each one stores a different coded packet
for all the versions it has heard from
and in this case again you can see that
if i connect to NEC servers NEC servers
I can get the latest common version and
the storage size is the worst case
storage size is the total number of
version x by c because each one uses an
NC MDS code V versions is v by c each
server stores v by c [ __ ] so the you
have these two baseline solutions the
question is how better how much better
you can get the main messages you can
improve by improve these but not by a
lot so our code constructions we have
code constructions which achieve 1 by C
by V so there's an integral T thing that
you can save on this can be twice as
good as this up to twice as good as this
and there's a lower bound which
essentially says that this is optimal so
at least the first order thing is that
if my number of concurrent versions
becomes large I approach replication
how much time do I have okay I just
explained the achievability and not
explain the converse the achievability
is the following I have I part so given
any state I make the following partition
server is in partition one if version
one is the latest version service in
partition to version two is the latest
version so given any state any subset of
versions I make this partition so there
are at most V partitions so there is at
least one partition in with C by V
servers this is a spigot pigeonhole
principle so a simple achievable scheme
is that the server in partition I just
stores 1 by C by V of version I so there
is one partition that is large enough
then can serve can serve my user and
this this this this scheme basically
work it's it's simple in the sense each
server just towards one version but just
large enough of that particular single
version okay the converse is actually
fairly simple i won't go into it because
of time so this is the summary this
lower bound is actually an infant
interesting clever information theory
problem you need some clever tricks
these numbers can actually be improved
and we did this in allerton 2014 but i
am giving these simpler versions because
they are more intuitive and they are
also technically improving these are
more technically challenging so it's
more of a technicality but it's still
interesting interesting exercises in
network information theory okay so we
started from this practical problem and
formulated a coding problem as mentioned
this is related to distributed storage
so you can we can add you can you know
add more bells and whistles to this
coding problem things like I think
yesterday tom was mentioning that these
versions typically tend to be correlated
right then that can bring storage cost
benefits to this this application you
can also add a bandwidth constraint to
and that might improve
improve latency of these so you can add
many bells and whistles to this problem
and I think they are all interesting
questions but before going into that
there is something else that I am
currently interested in that's keeping
me up late in the night and that is the
question of whether i can go back from
prac from this theory from theory back
to practice that is due the information
theoretic insights that that we have
obtained from this problem do they give
me fundamental no lower storage costs
lower bounds and improvements in storage
costs for this in this algorithm equaled
in this shared memory emulation one this
is something that I think is the first
step to ratify this model and this is
something we are excited about so with
this I conclude the top
maybe one question you were saying
before if I understand correctly that
answers could look reads could not
alternate between versions and when I
show the multi version coding it seems
that depending on which subsidies axes
and not sure what you mean by
alternation reads can be concurrent with
versions but if there are too many
rights in concurrent then some
correctness will be violated then I'll
do something bad about a sequence of
reads which are concurrent with a
certain right and then you get version
one version to version one pushing to
the beach yeah if the rates are
overlapping that that might be fine it's
more tricky than can be explained here
but the rules of the game yeah we need
to talk offline i guess it's bit tricky
so their next speaker may be one setting
up i can take you want you can set up
with a day from more quote across
provisions so it looks like you don't
really need to code across version
that's the converse results that we have
at least you can but you might not gain
as much you might not at least beat
replication when we the gaps are small
that's